some developing news to bring you the US
military just announcing a number of
service members were actually treated
for injuries after the missile attacks
this is going back to the missile
attacks on bases in Iraq early this
month here's Gabriel Elizondo in
Washington I know his little information
coming out at the moment what are you
hearing yeah the US military just
confirming within the last few minutes
that there were eight US service members
that were injured on that missile attack
at the al Asad Air Base in Iraq last
week now I should point out it does not
appear to be serious injuries
nevertheless this is what the Pentagon
is telling us they say that after the
missile attacks on the base many of the
service members were screened for
concussions which they say is very
common the the blast from missiles can
cause buildings to shake and rattle and
and can cause potentially concussions in
people that are even outside of the
immediate impact zone once these tests
were done on multiple service members
that were at that base there were eight
of them that needed further screening
they showed signs of some sort of
concussions that were they suffered
after the blasts from those missile
rocket launches three of the
servicemembers have been transported to
a u.s. airbase in Germany another three
have been transported to a u.s. Air Base
in Kuwait and they say they're doing
further testing the military says this
is all part a standard procedure no one
is in any sort of life-threatening
injuries or anything like that in fact
the military says that they are expected
after the screening is complete to be
sent back to Iraq so that's what we know
now there are injuries or I should say
there were injuries that this is the
first time that it was being disclosed I
should point out but it does not appear
to be very serious okay but just
interesting to keep an eye on isn't it
given Donald Trump said all was well
after those attacks Thank You Gabriel
Elizondo in Washington